Traffic sources can be classified in a number of ways. Data traffic might be
bursty. It might be weakly periodic, or
it might also be regular. Audio traffic is
typically continuous and strongly periodic. Video traffic
is continuous, but it's often bursty, due to
the nature of how video is often compressed, as we saw in a previous lecture.
And it may also be periodic. Typically, we
think of taking these sources and classifying them
into two kinds of traffic. One is a constant bit rate source or a CBR source. In
a constant bit rate source of traffic, traffic
arrives at regular intervals, and packets are typically the
same size as they arrive, resulting in a
constant bit rate of arrival. Audio is an example
of a constant bit rate source. Many other
sources of traffic are variable bit rate or VBR.
Video and data are often variable bit rate.
Typically when we shape CBR traffic, we shape it
according to a peak rate. Variable bit rate
traffic is shaped according to both an average rate,
and a peak rate. Where the average rate, might
actually be a small fraction of the peak rate.
You can see, that at certain times, the peak rate, might well exceed the average
rate. Let's now talk about how to perform
traffic shaping in a number of different ways.